the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
welcome happy Halloween and for and for
those of you watching this video at home
you'll be glad to know the whole
audience to join me and they're all
dressed out in costumes you know and
it's a real fun day here as as we do
this so making me not feel alone in my
costume you know a lot of moral support
there so that's great so yeah yeah so so
this is a lecture lecture oh five on
signal processing on databases just for
a recap for those of you mister or their
classes or going this out of order on
the web the you know signal processing
really alludes to detection Theory
finding things which alludes to the
underlying mathematical basis of that
which is linear algebra and the database
is relief refers to working with
unstructured data strings and other
types of things to to things that aren't
really talked about together but we're
bringing them together here because we
have lots of new datasets that require
it and so this this this talk is
probably the one that's getting most
into something that we would say relates
to detection theory because we're going
to be dealing with a lot with background
data models and in particular power laws
and methods of constructing power law
datasets methods of sampling and fitting
and using that as a basis for doing
doing the kind of work that you want to
do so moving in here so just our outline
it's a we got a lot of material to go
over here today this is all sort of
using the data set when we get into the
data set that we talked about in the
last lecture which is this Reuters data
set so we'll be applying some of these
ideas to that data set so just go to an
introduction here then I'm going to get
to sampling theory and sub sampling
Theory various types of distributions
and then end up with the Reuters data
set so the overall goal of this
lecture is to really develop a
background model for for these types of
datasets that is based on what I'm
calling a perfect power law and then
we're gonna basically after we can
construct a perfect law power law we're
gonna sample that power law and look at
what happens when we sample it what are
the effects of sampling it and then we
can use the power law to look at things
like deviations and such now you might
ask well why are we so concerned about
backgrounds and power laws and it's
because here's sort of the basis of
detection theory on one slide so in
detection theory you know you basically
have a model which consists of noise and
a single signal and you have two
hypotheses H 0 which is the there's only
noise in your data and H 1 that there's
signal plus noise and so essentially
when you do detection Theory what you're
doing is given these models okay you can
then compute sort of optimal filters for
answering the question is there a signal
there or is it just just noise that's
essentially what detection theory boils
down to in this status and now when we
deal with graph theory you know it's
obviously not so clean in terms of our
dimensions here you know we'll have some
kind of high dimensional space and our
signal will be projected into that high
dimensional space but nevertheless the
the the concept is still just as
important that we have noise and a
signal and that's what we're trying to
do here
detection theory works in the
traditional domains that we've applied
it to because we have a fairly good
model for the background which tends to
be Gaussian random noise is sort of the
kind of the fundamental sort of
distribution that we use in lots of our
our data sets and if we didn't have that
model it would be very difficult for us
to proceed with much of detection theory
and the Gaussian random noise model
works because in many respects if you're
collecting sensor data you really will
have Gaussian physics going on you also
you know law of law
numbers in terms of if you have lots of
sort of different distributions that are
pulled together they will end up
beginning to look like a Gaussian as
well so that's sort of what we have in
many of the traditional fields that
we've worked in in signal processing but
now we're serving this new area where a
lot of our datasets arrive from
artificial processes processes that are
a result of human actions be it data on
a network be it data in a social network
be it other types of data that have a
sort of a strong sort of artificial
element to them we find that the
Gaussian model does not sort of reveal
itself in the same way that we've seen
in other sets so what we need this we
really need a background model so we
have to have to do something about it so
there has been a fair amount of research
and literature to come up with sort of
first principles methods for creating
power law distributions in data sets we
talked a little bit about these
distributions in the previous lectures
and they've met with mixed results it's
been difficult to sort of come up with
what is the underlying sort of physics
of the processes that result in certain
vertices and graphs having an enormous
number of edges and other vertices only
having a few and so there has been work
on that encourage you to look at that
literature here we're going to do much
more of a sort of going from from the
reverse direction which is let's begin
by coming up with some way to construct
a perfect power law with no concept of
well what is the underlying physics
motivating this essentially a basic
linear model for a perfect power law
that we probably can do and then we'll
sort of go go from there and linear
models or something that we often use in
our business and it's a good good first
starting point so along those lines this
is a way to call construct you know a
perfect power law in a matrix so let me
this is basically a slide of definitions
here so let me spend a little
time going through them so we're gonna
represent our graph or our data as a
random matrix basically you know zero
where there's no connection between
these are the these are this is a set of
vertices connected with another set of
vertices there are and out of these
vertices and and in of these vertices if
you have a dot here the row corresponds
to the vertex at the edge left and the
column corresponds to the vertex that
the edge is going into so this adjacency
matrix a is just going to be constructed
by randomly filling this matrix with
entries and the only real constraint on
them is that when you sum a we're gonna
allow in multiple edges so you can have
more that values aren't just zero in one
but they can have more than that but
when you son some the matrix a all its
values up you get a value M which is the
total number of edges in in the graph so
we have essentially a graph with this
could be a bipartite graph or not but
you know with essentially n out vertices
and n vertices and M total edges the
perfect power law we're gonna have
essentially two perfect power law laws
here one on the out degree so if you sum
these rows okay and then you do a
histogram you're gonna want to produce a
histogram that looks something like this
so you have an out degree for each
vertex and this would show how many
vertices have that out degree and so our
power law says that these points should
fall on a slope with a negative power
law coefficient of alpha out so that's
essentially who the one definition there
and then we likewise have another going
in the for the other degree so the in
degrees have their own power law so
these are the definitions this is what
we're saying is a perfect power so we're
so we're saying a perfect power law has
these properties
now we're gonna attempt it constructed
we have no physical basis for saying why
the data should look this way we're just
saying this is a linear model of the
data and we're gonna construct it that
way and again these can be undirected
multi-edge we can allow self loops and
disconnected vertices and hyper edges
anything you can get by just randomly
throwing down values onto a matrix and
again the only constraint is that the
son that the the sum in both directions
is equal to the number of of edges so
given that can we construct such a thing
well it turns out we can construct such
a thing fairly simply in me and so in
matlab we can construct a perfect
power-law graph with this four line
function here we'll construct this it
will will construct a degree
distribution that has this property and
we the three a number parameters to this
new distribution are alpha which is the
slope D max which is the maximum degree
vertex and then this number n D which is
roughly proportional to the number of
Bin's
that we're gonna have here essentially
the number of points is not exactly that
but roughly proportional to that and so
when you do this little equation here
the first thing that you will see is
weird we are going to be creating a
logarithmic spacing of bins we kind of
need to do that here but but at a
certain point we get a below a value
where the spacing will be will have
essentially one bin per integer and so
these are two very separate regimes
we're gonna have one which is called a
root integer regime where basically each
integer has one you know is
representative it and then it
transitions to a logarithmic machine and
you might say this is somewhat
artificial it's actually very reflective
of what's really going on we really see
here you know we really have a D max we
really have almost always a account at
one and then you know we have a count of
two or three and then they start
spreading out and so this is just an
artificial way to create this type of
distribution which is a perfect power
law
fusion so it's a very simple very
efficient code for creating one of these
it has a smooth transition from what we
call the integer bins and the
logarithmic bins and it also gives a
very nice or what we call Poorman slope
as estimator so there's a lot of
research out there about how do you
estimate the slope of your power law and
there's all kinds of algorithms for
doing this well the simplest way is just
to take the two end points take the
first point and the last point and you
know you're perfectly fitting two points
and you could argue you're perfectly
fitting the two most important points
and you get this nice simple value for
the slope here in addition you can make
the argument that regardless of how you
bend the data you will always have these
two bins you will always have a band of
D Max and you always have a bin at one
and all the other bins are kind of kind
of be somewhat a matter of choice or a
fitting and so again that's another
reason to rationalize alpha so I would
say if you see if your plot your data
and you have to estimate an alpha that I
would just sort of say well here's
here's what you do and it's as good an
estimate of alpha as any and it's very
nicely defined so we recall that when
we're talking about estimating the slope
here this is the formula we're going to
use so so far this code is just just
constructed a degree a degree
distribution ie the degree and the
number of vertices with that degree will
be the outputs of this perfect power law
function we still have to assign that
degree distribution to an actual set of
edges okay and here's the code that will
do that for you it will say given a
degree distribution it will create a set
of vertices that that do that now the
actual pairing of the vertices into
edges is arbitrary and in fact these are
all different adjacency matrices for
for the same degree distribution that is
every single one of these has the same
degree distribution in the both the rows
and the columns so the actual which
vertices are connected to which is a
second-order statistic so the degree
distribution in this first-order stirred
but how you want to connect those
vertices up is somewhat arbitrary and so
that's a free of freedom that you have
here so for example if I just take the
vertices out of here and I just say
alright every single vertex in your list
I'm just gonna pair it up with yourself
I will get an adjacency matrix that's
all diagonals essentially all self loops
if I take that list and just randomly
reorder the vertex labels themselves
then I get something that looks like
this but I just randomly reorder the
edge pairs if I look like I get
something like this like this and if I
randomly real Abel both the vertices and
reconnect the the vertices into
different edges I get something like
this and for the most part when we talk
about our randomly generating our
perfect power laws we're going to talk
about this
which is probably most like what we what
we really encounter is essentially
something that's equivalent to randomly
labeling your vertices and then randomly
taking those vertices and randomly
pairing them together so that basically
talks about how we can actually
construct a graph from our perfect power
law edge now so this is a forward model
given a set of these this purpose sort
of three sort of parameters we can
generate a perfect power law but in in
in if we're dealing with data we often
want slightly different parameters so I
said before our three parameters were
alpha which is greater than zero D max
which is the which is the degree of the
the highest degree in the in the data
which we're saying is it's greater than
one and then this parameter n D which
roughly corresponds to the number of
Bin's so we can generate a power law
model for any of these values here that
satisfy these constraints so that's a
large number however what we'll
typically see
that we want to want to use these
parameters so we'll want to have an
alpha a number of vertices than a number
of edges as more often the parameters we
want to work with and we can compute
those by inverting these formulas that
is if we compute the degree we can come
we can summit to compute the number of
vertices and likewise we can sum the the
distribution times the degree to get the
number of edges so given these and alpha
and our model we can invert these all
right and what you see here is for a
given value of alpha the allowed values
of N and M okay given that is that is
the values of n M that will be a power
law and so what you see is that not all
combinations of vertices vertex count
and edge count can be constructed in
parallel there's a band here this is a
logarithmic graph it's a wide band but
there's a band here of allowable data
that will produce that and typically
what you see is kind of the middle of
this band is like a ratio of around 10
which happens to be kind of the magic
number that we see in lots of our data
sets when people say I have power law
data someone will ask you what's your
edge to vertex 2 ratio and the long we
say it's like 8 or 10 or 20 or something
like that and again you see it's because
in order for it to be power law data at
least according to this model it has to
fall into this band here you'll also see
this is a very nonlinear function here
and we'll get into fitting that later
and it's a nasty nasty function to
invert because we have integer data and
data that's almost continuous and it's
it's a nasty nasty but we can do it but
it's kind of a nasty business so but
given an alpha and an M that are
consistent we can actually then generate
a D Max and an n D that will sort of
best fit those parameters so let's do an
example here so I didn't just dress up
in this crazy outfit for nothing we have
a whole Halloween theme to our lecture
today so this is when I go trick or
treat trick-or-treating with my daughter
of course the our favorite thing is to
do the distribution of the candy when
we're done and so this shows last year's
candy distribution we'll see how it
berries as you can see Hershey's
chocolate bars not surprisingly
extremely popular what else is popular
here swedish fish
not so popular Nestle Crunch Bars not so
popular again what's actually found this
someone but this list hasn't changed
since when I went trick-or-treating this
is a tough list to break into you know
getting a new candy that makes it to
Halloween worthy candy is pretty hard so
but so this year shows the distribution
of all the candy that we collected and
here's some basic information so we have
77 pieces of candy or distinct edges we
had 19 types of candy our edge to vertex
ratio was for the the the d-max was 15
so we had 15 Hershey's Kisses and one
that's that we had eight types of candy
that we only got one up and then our
power with slope was was alpha and then
our fit parameters to this when we
actually fit where we got 77 21 and Emma
runa 3.7 and this shows you the data so
this is the candy degree and this is the
number and this shows you what we
measured this is the the poor man's
slope here this is the model and then
one thing we can do is actually which is
very helpful is we can rebuild the
measured data using the bins extracted
from the model and that gives you these
these red X's here or plus signs here
and we'll discover that's very important
because the data you have is often very
rarely bend in a way that's proper for
looking at for seeing the proper
distribution and we can actually use
this model to come up with what a better
set of bins would be and then bin the
data with respect to that so that's just
an example of this in actual practice
so now that we have have a mechanism for
generating perfect power law let's see
what happens when we sample it let's see
what happens when we do the things to it
that we typically do to clean up our
data I bring this up because in standard
graph theory as I've talked about in the
in in previous lectures we often have
what we call random undirected or any
graphs which are basically vertices
without direction and usually the edges
are unweighted so we just have like a 0
or a 1 so very simplified simplify
graphs I'm actually going to getting all
hot here so so a lot of our graph theory
is based on these types of graphs and as
we've talked about before that our data
tends to not look like that but so one
of the things we do so that we can apply
the theory to to that data is that we
often make the data look like that so
we'll often make the data undirected
we'll often make the data you know
basically unweighted and other types of
things so we can apply all the theory
that we've developed over the last
several decades on these particular
types of very well studied graphs so now
that we have a perfect power law graph
we can see what happens if we apply
those same Corrections to the data and
so here's what we see so we generated a
perfect power law graph so alpha is 1.3
the d-max 1,000 or ND was 50 this
generated a data set with 18,000
vertices and 84,000 edges and so here is
a very simple way to make it we're gonna
make it
undirected by basically taking the
matrix and adding its transpose and then
taking the upper diagonal this is
actually the best way to make an
adjacency matrix undirected to take that
upper upper portion because
a lot of the statistical you won't you
basically it saved you having to deal
with a lot of annoying factors of two so
a lot of times it will just do a plus a
transpose but then you get these
annoying factors of two laying around
and so this is a way to sort of not do
that so we're getting rid of we've made
it undirected we're made it undirected
by doing that we're going to make it
unweighted by basically doing converting
them everything to a zero one and then
back to doubles so that makes it
unweighted and then we're getting rid of
the diagonal so that eliminates
selfloops so so we've done all these
things we've cleaned up our data in this
way and so what happens well so the the
triangles were the input model well now
we've cleaned up our data and we see
this sort of mess that we've done to our
data and in fact I'll call this call
this of keeping with our Halloween theme
here we'll call this our witch's broom
distribution here and if anybody has
looked at degree distributions on data
will be like you'll recognize this shape
instantly because you have kind of this
bendiness coming up here and then sort
of fanning out down here very common
thing that we see in in in the data sets
that we plot and in fact you know
there's not an insignificant amount of
literature devoted to trying to
understand these bumps and Wiggles and
do they really mean something underlying
about the physical phenomenon that's
taking place and while it's the case
that those bumps and Wiggles may
actually be representative of some
physical phenomenon based on this we
also have to concede the fact it's also
consistent with our cleaning up
procedure that is the thing we're trying
to do to make our data better is
introducing nonlinear phenomena on the
data which we may confuse with real
phenomena so this is a very much a
cautionary tale and so based on that I
certainly encourage people not to clean
up their data in that way and sort of
keep the directedness don't throw away
the self loops keep
waited miss do your degree distributions
in this way and live with the fact that
that's what your data really is like and
trying to understand it that way
rather than try and clean it up in this
way sometimes you've no choice the
algorithm that you have will only work
on data they've been cleaned up in this
way but you have to recognize you are
introducing a new phenomenon it's a
highly nonlinear process that's cleaning
up and you have to be careful about that
so however given that given that we've
done this is there a way that we can
recover the original power law so we can
try that so we have here is the data
that we this the the the original data
that we cleaned up is now these circles
okay and we're gonna take that data set
and compute an alpha and nm from it from
using our our inversion formulas and
then compute what the power law of that
would be so that's this the triangles so
here's our here's our power poor-man's
alpha fix this is our model all right
this is what the model is these
triangles here's the model were saying
and then we can say aha let's use the
bins that came from this model to rebid
this these circles onto these red plus
signs here so that's our new dataset and
what you see is that we've done a pretty
good job of recovering the original
power law so if we had data that we
observe to look like this we wouldn't be
sure it was a power law like we don't
know it's like well what's this Bend
here and what's this fanning out here
but then if you go through this process
and rebid it you can be like oh no that
really looks like a power law and so
that's a way of recovering the power law
that we may have lost through some
filtering procedure here's another
example so what we're gonna do is
essentially take our matrix and compute
the correlation of it we've talked a lot
about you know if we say have an
incidence matrix we multiply it to do
correlation and this will in this case
we're treating our random matrix as not
an adjacency matrix but as an incidence
matrix or randomly gen
incidence matrix and so these are again
the parameters that we use we're
converting it to all unweighted all
zeros and ones and then we are
correlating it with itself to construct
the adjacent image taking the upper
diagonal and then and then removing the
diagonal and this is the result of what
we see so here's our input model again
the triangles and then this is the
measured the measured what we get out
from there and if you saw this you might
be like wow that's a really good power
law in fact I've certainly seen date I
mean most of time I would see yet that
is a power law distribution we
absolutely have a power law distribution
however if we then apply our procedure
so again we have our measured data okay
we're going to do our parameters here
get our poor-man's alpha parameter and
then fit the triangles are the new fit
okay and then we use those bins to rebid
and we see here that when we actually
rebuild the data we get something looks
very much not like a power dose from the
law distribution so here's an example of
reverse before we had data that didn't
look like a power law but when we bend
it we recovered the power law here we
have data that made that you know just
serving this random meaning may look
like a power law we actually see it has
this bump and in continuing with our
Halloween theme we can call this the
witch's nose distribution because it
comes along here as this giant bump and
then goes back to a power law and this
actually there's meaning for this that
we will we and we will see this later in
the actual data that this is not just
that when you do these correlation
matrices certain types of them
particularly self correlations are very
more likely will produce this type of
distribution but again even though we
have this bump you would still argue
that our linear perfect power law is
still a very good first-order fit so
we've still captured most of the dynamic
range of the of the distribution and
this is now a delta from that and so
we're very comfortable with that right
we start with our linear models that
models most of the data and then we have
a second order if we wanted to we could
go in and come up with some
second order you know subtract the
linear model from here and you would see
sort of some kind of hump you know
distribution here and you could then
model your data as a linear model plus
some kind of correction again very
classic signal processing way to deal
with our data and certainly seems as
relevant here as anywhere else let's see
here so
and here again so the power law can be
preserved as we talked about there so
moving on another phenomenon that's
often documented in the literature is
called densification the in fact there's
many Papers written on what is called
densification this is the observation
that if you construct a graph okay and
you compute the ratio of the edges to
vertices over time the that ratio will
go up and there's a lot of research
talking about the physical phenomenon
that might produce that type of effect
and so while that physical phenomena
might be there it's also a byproduct of
just sampling the data so for instance
here what we're going to do is we've
created our perfect power law graph and
we're going to sample it we're basically
going to take sub samples of that data
and we're going to do it in little
chunks about 10% of the data at a time
and that and the the triangles and the
circles show when we look at each set of
data independently and then then we have
these lines that show what happens when
we look when we sort of do it
cumulatively is when we basically we
like we take 10% of the data than 20% of
data and 30% and move on here and we
have two different ways of sampling our
data here random is I'm just taking that
whole matrix and I'm randomly picking
edges out of it and what you see is that
each sample okay has a relatively low
vertex - I mean edge to vertex
distribution but as you add more and
more and more up it gets denser and this
is just simply the fact that given a
finite number of vertices okay you
eventually if you kept on adding edges
and edge and edges eventually you would
go this would become infinite if you add
an infinite number of edges to a finite
similar of vertices then the they will
get denser and denser and denser and
denser and this is sort of a byproduct
of treating these as sort of zero and
once you know and and and not and not
recognized so so this just did naturally
occur
through sampling the linear sampling
here's where basically I'm taking whole
rows at a time or I could have taken
whole columns at a time so I'm taking
each row in mentioning all right I'm
dropping them out and there you say it's
constant so I'm basically for each
essentially taking a whole vertex and
adding at a time and here the sampling
is somewhat independent of at the
densification you know if you sample it
whole rows the density of that will be
the same as if you did so this is just
good to know and then good to know about
sampling and these phenomena can take
place and how sampling can play an
important role in the in the data that
we observe another phenomena that's been
studied extensively is what happens to
the slope of the degree distribution as
you add data and again we do the exact
same type of sampling and you see here
that when we just you know this data had
a slope I believe at 1.3 and you can see
if we if we sample it randomly just take
random vertices that the slope starts
out very very high and each sample stays
stays high but when we start
accumulating them they start converging
on the true value from from converging
from a bola above and likewise and you
do linear sampling you have a direction
and the opposite in the opposite way and
they both end up converging on to the
true value here at 1.3 and so again this
just shows that the slope of your degree
distribution is also very much a
function of the sampling it could be
also be a function of the underlying
phenomenon but again a cautionary tale
that one needs to be very aware of how
one sampling and again these are these
these perfect power law data sets are a
very useful tool for doing that so if
you have a real data set and your
sampling in some way and you want to
know what are what is may be real
phenomenon versus what a sampling
affects if you go and generate a perfect
power law that's an approximation in
this data set you can then very quickly
see which which phenomena are just a
result of sampling a perfect power law
in which phenomena are maybe indicative
as some deeper underlying correlations
between the data
the data so again a very useful useful
tool here moving on we're going to talk
about sub sampling and one of the
problems that we have is very large data
sets and often we can't compute the
degree distribution on the entire data
set or we can't you know and this has
sort of been a bread and butter of
signal processing for years where if we
want to compute a background model that
we don't just simply sum up all the data
that we randomly select data from from
the data set and we use that as a model
of our background and that's a much more
efficient way from a computational and
data handling perspective than simply
computing the mean or the variance based
on the entire data set so again you know
we need good background estimation in
order to do our anomaly detection and
again it's prohibitive to traverse the
data so the question is can we
accurately estimate the background from
a sample so let's see what happens we
have a perfect power law we can we can
look at what happens when we sample that
so we've generated a power law okay and
this is not this have changed a change
this may look like the degree
distribution but it's actually a
different plot so this is showing every
single vertex in the data set all right
and this shows the in degree of that
vertex and we've sorted them so the
highest degree vertex is over here and
the lowest degree vertex is over here
okay so this is all all all the vertices
okay and and so this is the true data
and this is what happens when we take a
140th sample I just say I'm only going
to take 140 features what does it look
like some relatively simple bath here
which I won't go over but it's therefore
we can actually come up with the
correction allows us to sample that data
based on the median distributions I
apologize for the slides we will correct
them for the for the web and when we
when we go out there so all right so
moving on so one of the things we talked
about sampling and we talked mainly
about sort of single distributions we
can also talk about joint distributions
so we can actually
use the degree as a way of labeling the
vertices and look at them so it's a way
it's sort of compressing you know if we
just say we're gonna we're gonna stable
each vertex by its degree this is a way
of compressing many degree many vertices
into into a smaller dimensional space
way to look at that and we can then
count the the correlations we can look
at the distribution of how many edges
are there from the group from vertices
of this degree two vertices of that
degree and so it's a tool for projecting
our data and understanding what's going
on and we can also then repin that data
with a power law which will make it more
more easily understood so if we look
here we see that we had the degree
distribution so this shows us the for a
perfect power law data for vertices with
this degree in and this degree out how
many how many edges there were between
them and as you see here you know
obviously there was a lot of vertices
here between low degree edges and not so
much here but this is somewhat a
misnomer because of the way the data
comes out we're not really bidding it
properly however if we go and fit a
perfect power law to this data alright
and then pick a new set of bins based on
those okay so Reeb in the day we can see
here that we get a much smoother uniform
distribution so while here we may have
thought that this was an artificially
low you know dense not dense region this
is very artificially high what you see
here is when you rebuild this and this
that there's a very smooth distribution
from what we expect for our perfect
power law here that this is a fairly
uniform distribution with respect to
that and so basically essentially puts
more bins where we care where we
actually have data as opposed to wasting
bins over here we don't already have any
data
using our perfect power law model we can
actually compute analytically what this
should be so here's an example of what
that looks like and again very similar
to what we see and given the data and a
model for the data we can then compute
the the ratio of the observed to the
model to get a sense of you know when
what what data is is is unusual versus
versus what we expect from a perfect
mount our linear fit and we see that
very clearly here so this is the data
just dividing the data by the model here
and you see again
you see all this data appears like it's
you know this is the ratio the log of
the ratio and so it's a zero means that
it's essentially the ratio is 1 so all
this is expected and then we see all
these fluctuations here things that are
higher than we expected and things that
are lower than we expected and so this
is the classic the point the time where
you see this most is whenever they look
show you map the United States by county
of some you know maybe like it's classic
is like a cancer cluster or heart
disease or any phenomenon and what you
see is that certain counties in the
western part of United States are
extremely healthy and certain counties
are just deadly and it's just a fact
that they're very sparsely populated and
so they're dealing with small numbers
effect here so basically this is just
showing you oscillations between 0 & 1
here so we're we call Poisson sampling
and so it makes it very difficult to
know what what what what what those what
those are however if we rebid the data
and then divide by the model we see that
the vast majority of our data as
expected is in this very sort of you
know in this in this normal regime
another thing we can actually do is we
can look at like the most unexpected
data set so we can look at that sort of
the most typical data set oh these got
moved here didn't they I don't know
what's going on with the PowerPoint
today but this shows us the surpluses
the deficits and the most typical
so here's like you know the the most
extreme been the most underrepresented
bend in the sort of the most average bin
and these are the areas that they
correspond to in the real data set so
you can use this to find extremes based
on a statistical test and again you see
that here again we have we have these
different that shows what the measured
over expect it is versus measured and
you can see this is this is the original
data set and this is the Reeb in data
set and you see the rebidding sure
removes a lot of these very sparse
points over here and gives you a very
narrow a distribution of around what you
expected you can actually go and find
the selected edges if you want so this
just shows the different types of edges
the you know the maximum if you actually
wanted to go and look at those edges
this would be maximum these would be the
minimum and this these are the other
types so it's a useful thing you can get
and go say alright we've we found that
if we have an artificially high
correlation between vertices with this
degree in this degree we can then
backtrack and find out which specific
vertices there are and see if that's
anything that's interested we can also
use this plot to look at these questions
of edge order and so hopefully this will
work today so here's a if I if I if I
randomly select vertices and I compute
their their degree verses so basically
what we did before we sub sample and
then compute over what is expected and
we play this and you can just see here
we get this roof when we randomly select
the vertices you know we basically get
kind of a typical you know they'll each
sample looks very much the same again up
there in these high degrees we have this
plus on sampling effect where we have
some just you know this is we have no
vertices so we get a 0 which is sort of
lower than expected I mean if we have
like two vertices we get higher than
expected and so again we still have that
possum effect
interestingly if we do linear sampling
which we take whole rows at a time we
get a very different type of phenomenon
so you see you get these whenever you do
whenever you do run into a high degree
row by definition it is unusual which
again means you have to be very careful
you're going to run into this high
degree row eventually by sampling but
you have to be careful it's like oh my
goodness this is very very unusual type
of thing so again cautionary tale about
about sampling alright so we've talked a
lot about the theory here let's get into
some real data so this is our Reuters
data again I showed it to you the other
day the various document distributions
we have in this case eight hundred
thousand documents 47,000 extract
identities for a total of 6 million
essentially edges so we have it's a
bipartite graph or assumption between
documents and for different types and we
can now look at the different the degree
distributions of the different classes
and see see what we have so the first
one we want to look at are the locations
and so we look at the distribution of
the documents and the entities so
basically imagine we took so we're very
clear here so what I'm doing is just
taking this part of the matrix and the
distribution of the documents is summing
up the row summing this way and the
distribution of the locations is summing
up and down along the columns so for
each one of these types we can do those
different types we have essentially two
different degree distributions one
associated with the documents and one
associated with the entities so this
shows us our document distribution so we
have the measured data we have our fit
we have our model and then our rebidding
and you know you could say that this is
approximately a power law and when you
read in it that this sort of s-shaped
effect is still there which probably
means it's really there there's
something going on in the data that
really is making this bowing effect and
so that's really there i'll likewise
here we have our model we have the
measured data we have our model alpha
which is the blue line we have the
fit and then our rebidding and again you
could say the the power law model is a
pretty good fit but again we have
something going on here some kind of
phenomenon going on there and we can
didn't need this for each type we can
look at the organization's again we
don't have as many organizations again
similar types of phenomenon here this is
so sort of sparse it's difficult to
really say what's going on here of
course we do do people which is of
course our people always are the first
thing that you talk about when you talk
about power law distributions and again
very nicely we have our our measured
data and our fit and again we see this
sort of bent broom distribution here but
you know bending and then with sort of
this fan out effect here but then when
we model it andrey bennett we get
something that looks much more like a
true power law and you can see that very
nicely here with the with the actual
person data a very very good power law
so this tells us that regardless of what
this underlying data looks like this is
probably really is a power law
distribution and then we have the times
and again a similar type of thing here
different types of things and we
actually have a little spike here the
the reuters data has a certain sort of
collection of times associated with the
actual filing of events there's only 35
of them and so we do get a little spike
here which is actually what we expect
although you wouldn't see that and
really clearly in the true data but when
yuri bin it this this bump comes out
fairly clearly so again proper bidding
extremely important we can look at our
correlations as well so let's just look
at the person person correlations and
again what we saw here is sort of we see
this as the raw data so something looks
very much like a power law but when we
go through a ribboning process we see
this kind of as witch's nose effect here
really in the data so there's to tell
you it you know to first order to power
law but you actually have this this
correlation taking place here right here
so that's that's you know something that
really seems to be taking place the same
you see the same thing when we do time
you know again
we can look at document let's now look
at sampling so again this is the same
sampling and we did we're gonna now
basically look at the document
densification so this is selecting whole
rows we select a whole document so we're
getting a whole row and this just shows
you the four different types here and
you see that they behave they behave
exactly as expected each individual
sample is reflective of the overall
densification because you're taking
whole rows okay now let's take the
entities so now we're cutting across
these and now you see something that
looks much more like random sampling
when you randomly sect a selected entity
okay that's sort of a random set of
documents and again the individual
samples but when you start summing them
up you see that they get denser and
denser and denser so you know individual
document has a sort of a good sample of
the overall distribution when you pick a
person you're you know as you as you
take a higher fraction of the data
you're gonna get more and more and more
with that so again all consistent with
what we saw before a little noisier to
see here but trust me the power law
x-point also behaves exactly as we
expected likewise this is essentially a
linear sampling and here's the random
sampling behaving exactly as we expect
it we can look at the joint
distributions so here's the actual this
is the location cross correlation so
they're showing you basically the
document versus entity degree
distributions so this is the measured
and it's been rebuild this is measured
divided by the expected so the expected
ribbond this is the measure divided by
the model and here's the model and
expected divided by the model and you
can basically compare all these
different types to use statistic
different create different statistical
tests and actually we can find here the
measure dreeben divided by the expected
ribbond we can get to our sort of our
surpluses and deficits and other types
of things in the actual data and so here
you see something that maybe the
like a artificially high grouping here
some artificially low and some expected
you can then use these as ways to
actually go and find anomalous documents
or documents are like if you say look
this is the most typical type of thing
you know I mean people like well why
would you try and find the most normal
well a lot of times you want to be able
to like in terms of summarization be
like here's a very representative you
know set of documents they have the
statistical properties is very
consistent with everything else
because people want like well what does
that mean to be that so again a very
useful way to look at the data do the
same thing with organization again you
know basically get the measured Reeb and
the measured divided by the expected the
expected rebend
the model if we fit the model and the
various different sort of ratios of all
of them which you can do to find very
it's sort of outliers and such again a
very useful interesting that it picked
the most representative one way up here
so that's an interesting so here's a
very unusual representative sample so uh
persons you can do the same thing and I
guess one of the things I'm also I'm is
that you see that these these all don't
look the same right I mean you hopefully
from looking at these it's like this one
the the location distribution is clearly
you know little similar to the
organization distribution but the person
distribution looks very different and
the time distribution looks very
different so you see that you have to be
careful about sort of sometimes will
just take all these different categories
and lump them together in one big
distribution and here's a situation like
these are really pretty different things
and you really want to treat them as
sort of sort of four distinct classes of
types of things so as an example of
selected edges you know this just goes
the most typical this just shows sort of
various sort of entities that were
selected and very representative
document this is a very low degree you
know various sentence so this might be
you know show you entities here's the
kind of surplus example just and going
be going and actually finding those
edges same with same with person sort of
very sort of generic people you know
higher degree here's a very low so this
person Jeremy Smith is very
unusual in terms of what they connected
with a surplus ones here I don't really
read that over there but just examples
of things that you can actually use this
to go in and actually find things all
right so that brings us at the end to
the lecture part so just again
developing this background model is very
important for for the graphs based on
the perfect power law gives us a very
simple heuristic for creating a linear
model we can then really sort of
quantify the effects of sampling which
is very important again traditional
sampling approaches can easily create
nonlinear phenomenon that we have to be
careful of and be aware of it allows us
to develop techniques for comparing real
data with pert with power law fits that
we can then use statistical tests for
finding unusual bits of data it's a very
classic detection theory here you know
come up with a model for the background
create a linear fit for that background
then use that model to then quantify the
data to see which things are unusual
again just using very classic detection
Theory the techniques again having a
background model being sort of the
linchpin of doing that and I'm not
saying that this this power this is very
recent work you know this is this this
power law model you know something we
did in the last year or so we just
published it you know this summer I
can't guarantee that in three or four
years from now that this people will
still be using this model because it is
very new but I think this is
representative the kinds of things that
will be in three or four or five years
that people it may not be this but
something like this to sort of
characterize our data and so I think
it's very useful there all right so with
that we will take a short break and then
we will show the example code and talk
about the assignment so very good thank
you very much